let's play
I live my life a quarter mile at a time
nothing else matters
for those 10 seconds or less
I'm free
the open road could take you anywhere to
friends to family we know he's an
O'Conner but he's also a Toretto the law
for adventure let's do it to see
something new when he main dream just to
come back home again as we go the facet
of here is saga has explored the endless
possibility of the open road from the
streets just outside downtown Los
Angeles we've taken you to Miami we've
taken you to Tokyo
the Dominican Republic Rio
Londyn Abu Dhabi and now our name is
known all over the world
we have raced for speed race for honor -
Don was had you greens or cities tumbled
down mountains and even dropped out of
the sky but no matter how our adventures
grow fast and furious is always about
one very important thing family the most
important thing in life will always be
the people in this room
saluton if Amelia our family of
characters do everything for each other
and with each other
for the millions who make up our global
family of fans we push ourselves to go
further and do better time half
time
alone we never ride alone we never ride
alone this time it ain't just about
being fast now we embark on our next
chapter our family will be challenged
like never before
by adversaries who show no mercy testing
that farm that has always kept us
together
most ambitious most entertaining fastest
and most furious Rania
this is fast and furious
you
you